still a spring in his step but this now
the end of the road for Boris Johnson
his wife and other Die Hard supporters
in full Applause still but it couldn't
mask the mood these MPS comforting each
other as they came to witness something
they fought hard not to see as did he
but after days of Defiance the Prime
Minister now reluctantly relenting it is
clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader of that
party and therefore a new prime minister
and I've agreed with sir Graham Brady
the chairman of our back bench MPS that
the process of choosing that new leader
should begin now except in new
leadership now necessary but fast
appointed reminder of what this leader
achieved thank you for that incredible
mandate the biggest conservative
majority since 1987 the biggest share of
the vote since
1979. and making it very clear to the
public that he neither one appeared nor
in his mind deserved to go in the last
few days I've tried to persuade my
colleagues that it would be eccentric to
change governments when we're delivering
so much I regret and not to have been
successful in those arguments and of
course it's painful and not to be able
to see through so many ideas and
projects myself but as we've seen at
Westminster the herd instinct is
powerful when the herd moves it moves
and my friends in politics no one is
remotely indispensable acknowledging
them he couldn't carry on but Mr Johnson
true to himself until the very end No
Remorse and no mention even that this
was a resignation what he did offer up
was regret I know that there will be
many people who are relieved and uh
perhaps quite a few who will also be
disappointed and I want you to know how
sad I am to be giving up the best job in
the world
but them's the breaks even if things can
sometimes seem dark now
our future together is golden
thank you all very much
thank you and with that the Johnson era
Drew to a close turning his back on a
bruising period
outside the Downing Street Gates chance
of liar and a sense of Fury but it was
descent on the inside that caused his
downfall an avalanche of resignation
letters triggered by previously loyal
MPS even the new Chancellor Nadim zahari
not resigning but urging Boris Johnson
to go from the very top to the bottom
staunch allies call in time can you make
big decisions over the next two three
months but the business of running the
country goes on the Prime Minister
appointing a new cabinet yet even those
in post wondering what comes next but
clear of one thing policy decisions are
now out of the prime minister's hands
here's the thing this is a caretaker
government it's not the business of this
prime minister to start announcing new
policies or taking government into a
different direction it's his business to
manage a transition in an orderly way
and through that process actually redeem
some of the ground that he clearly lost
yesterday when he stubbornly refused to
resign so he's an administrator rather
than a leader at this point but I think
he has to be
but some MPS in the former conservative
prime minister think Boris Johnson
should leave office right now his
stubbornness sparking an angry mood
across Westminster those who are right
by his side as this week played out
battled with him to The Bitter End there
were just too many colleagues that
didn't want him to carry on the mood
overall is as strange as you know
incredibly busy because of you know
these events and people coming and going
once the decision was made a bit more
calm and then he you know obviously went
out on the doorsteps
um you know there were there were
obviously tears from you know loyal
ex-members or members of Staff but also
after a short pulls the the knowledge
that actually we still need to govern
and many MPS can't really see how Boris
Johnson can I just worry that he isn't
going to be able to bring the stability
that we need I he's got a Chancellor
who's already said he doesn't have any
confidence in him and two or three other
members of the cabinet the Attorney
General is outwardly campaigning for his
job it's a it's just not a credible way
to form a government Boris Johnson will
always be remembered as the politician
who brought brexit to Great Britain at
his height he was the most successful
conservative party leader at The Ballot
Box since the days of Margaret Thatcher
he won a huge mandate in 2019 and with
it the opportunity to potentially lead
the country for a decade or more that
was the plan but it didn't work out like
that instead he leaves office as one of
the shortest serving prime ministers in
history a man who in the end let his
party and his people down Boris Johnson
is a politician who is as charismatic
and talented as he is destructive and
flawed and it was Boris Johnson who
brought himself down
the opposition leader today at Wimbledon
enjoying the view of a very different
contest but still trying to hasten the
departure of the PM they've declared him
unfit to be prime minister they can't
inflict him on the country for the next
few months if they don't get rid of him
we will bring that vote with no
confidence in the National interest
because we can't go on with this broken
government led by this discredited prime
minister
this a dramatic end to a highly dramatic
Premiership Boris Johnson now with
limited supporters around him but still
as defiant in giving up power as he was
in taking it an emotional end to a
tumultuous tenure he a politician who
will always be remembered if not always
for the right reasons Beth Rigby Sky
News Westminster
well Beth Rigby is here and Beth never
has British politics seen a week like
this it took nearly half of those on the
government payroll to resign for him to
realize that the game was up yes that's
right Anna look I've been in this
business for over a decade now and I've
never experienced quite what has just
happened in the past 48 hours it's
actually quite mind-boggling to see the
spectacle of Boris Johnson Clinging On
and that brutal end battle when in the
end as you said 59 government ministers
nearly half of the payroll having to
walk out before he finally accepted that
the game was up what does it tell us
about him well it tells us that he is a
politician who has always defied
convention that always believed he could
defy political gravity if you look at
his career he was the man that won
London not once but twice as a
conservative a labor City he was the guy
uh that people would have thought was
maybe pro-european but turned into the
cheerleader of the brexiteers he was the
man that won the biggest majority of a
conservative prime minister since
Margaret Thatcher an 80-seat majority
smashing down Labor's old red wall
building a new Coalition of conservative
voters they used to say he was the
Heineken politician being able to reach
parts of the country other conservatives
couldn't but he was also a Marmite
politician people loved him or hated him
and what has happened over the past few
days within the party is this distaste
for him has just become so overwhelming
that his MPS had to see him go but I was
at an event tonight with lots of MPS
around and as one of his supporters said
to me what have they done that in the
end they will regret losing Boris
Johnson that was a close Ally of his
others now thinking about what comes
next in terms of who who is the leader
but this was a politician who had it all
in his hands he had the power to reshape
the country he had in his gift as I was
saying to potentially win not just
another election but even one after that
and through his own missteps his own
miscalculations he has brought it all
crashing down and a man that should have
been in there at least until the mid of
this mid decade is now only got a couple
of months left it's extraordinary